les ivelinois doivent se préparer les
éoliennes vont pousser à côté de leur
maison d'ici à 2020 la consultation du
SRE francilien le schéma régional éolien
pour l'Île-de-France vient de se
terminer ce plan définit les zones
favorables au développement de l'énergie
éolienne en clair le SRE est une sorte
de nomenclature pour les collectivités
locales ce seront aux élus locaux de
mettre en place des projets de
construction de parc éolien sur ces
zones le chéma éolien ne définit pas des
projets éoliens mais définit à l'échelle
régionale de territoires sur les ell
pourront être portés des projets la
nuance est subtile mais elle est
d'importance puisque les projets éoliens
très concrètement seront portés à
l'initiative des maires des différentes
communes du territoire situé en zones
favorabl ou des présidents
d'intercommunalité situés dans les zones
favorables du chin régional éolen sur
l'île-de-fance 671 villes sont
concernées dont 109 communes dans les
ivelines cette carte montre que dans le
département trois zones ont été
sélectionnées pour l'implantation
d'éoliennes au sud du département sur la
plaine d'aabi à à l'ouest près d'Oudan
et au sud de Mantel jolie l'association
Eveline environnement redoute pourtant
une facture salée pour le consommateur
aucune inquiétude à avoir pour le
conseil régional la deuxème énergie
renouvelable celle qui arrive tout de
suite après l'hydraolique c'est
l'énergie éolienne pour un prix compris
entre 69 et 80 € du mgawh donc vous êtes
aujourd'hui sur une énergie renouvelable
qui est compétitive par rapport à des
énergies conventionnel voire même qui
sont enfin voir même une énergie qui est
située en dessous du coût de production
des énergies F
des énergies cl mais l'association evel
environnement s'inquiète aussi du danger
sur la faune et le paysage le plan
assure qu'aucune éolienne ne serait
implantée par exemple à moins de 500 m
d'habitation à l'heure actuelle il faut
aller à guitrancour pour trouver la
seule éolienne du département d'ici à
2020 100 à 180 éoliennes devrait être
installé dans la région